let's go on my name is Pierre pack today
we have a very special game we have game
of the year 420 blazeit read me you
scrub it's made in seven days with a
shitload of money spent on the asset
store hashtag I'm excited to play this
disclaimer don't sue me
got it oh my god it's [ __ ] amazing
it's almost like they're coming into my
man game of the year Wow
/ 10 hashtag rake the Edition good I'm
glad we got the right Edition if it's
not directed agent I don't wanna hello
and I will be giving you your secret
mission instructions today how nice
enter their secret underground lizard
place and 160 no scope 420 blaze it ball
man kit is your standard-issue Mountain
ok Oh blast nice don't forget to drink
doing eat Doritos along the way and buy
all new board action retos you will
enjoy it I will enjoy it
[ __ ] y'all enjoy it MLG is counting on
you all I've got to [ __ ] up them yellow
does that mean I have one life in the
game work
Oh wrong way shut up Louis looks pretty
where's my sniper how the [ __ ] do they
expect me to noscope what that lens
flare oh yeah
oh that lens what the [ __ ] me better
drink some margaritas in that new F to
open do I pick them up with it
yeah I do yay gotta have those to read a
spray ah this must mean we're in the
right place share yourself lizard people
if someone watching me they you bros
what does Coca Cola's doing here
I don't know what's going on
ah what that I can't
I'm [ __ ] peasants the [ __ ]
oh my god
[ __ ]
oh so [ __ ] good look how many
Microsoft boys I have all y'all haters
pitiful [ __ ] off
boria playing this game nonlinear Ithaca
that's [ __ ] shits over all right what
do we get
[Music]
nonlinear gameplay section shrek swamp
too spooky for me why should we pick all
right I'm a man all right I can deal all
nice we have the golden will a king
where the [ __ ] is strike get [ __ ] a bad
game
[ __ ] a nice wish ha ha ha that
explosion nice Wow where's shrink swamp
where the [ __ ] is it it's my fate what
is that what the [ __ ] is that
Jesus all right
we blaze it up by let's go to shrink
swamp get playing keep [ __ ] casuals
ah damn I'm pretty sure this is what
ellezi feels like
[ __ ] me oh god nothing [ __ ] again like
that [ __ ]
please
get a heart attack why am I not in this
game what the pot [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
god I gotta I gotta get no Sonic for
[ __ ] sake is that it the door I [ __ ]
until the fedora oh [ __ ] see that
look at this look at this
ah Jesus dad knows go oh I'm almost
higher than my Katy what happens I
should take oh [ __ ] yeah another night
my ears are bleeding it's coming down I
can feel it
I [ __ ] love it the sweet burn the
sweetbreads escape gypsy man
this trick he's trying to noscope me
oh man oh man checking senators gonna be
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] how to kill
Tammy Oh
[ __ ] ads watch this trick
[ __ ] me what finicky potty
why would you look at me
oh I am here spooderman the same
question to you but if I am you
never loved a night of partying take
you'll never get me
you'll never get me a yeah me I need a
part two and I need it now
Jesus why do I have an erection I don't
know just what oh man that's the most
thrilling experience of my life
it's no point of doing anything else
anymore might as well display it again I
guess oh my [ __ ] god yeah I'll leave
without looking through this game I
think it's the type of game that's free
but you can donate and that's [ __ ] it
I don't know what to say but thank you
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one stay awesome bros love you burn